(sparse violin notes)
- Imagine you're a sailor,
working on a Great Lakes freighter
for two months at a time and
you need your mail delivered.
Well, that's where we come in.
(accordion pulses)
My name is Jim Hogan and I'm the owner
and the fourth generation of
the J.W. Westcott Company.
This company was started in 1874
by my great-grandfather,
Captain John Ward Westcott.
We operate a shore-to-
ship and ship-to-shore
delivery boat in the Port of Detroit.
We're the only floating zip code in
actually the United States
and it still holds true today.
Any package that's got that 48222 zip code
is going to arrive here at our station.
On any given day, we receive mail
and packages in the morning.
You see the various pigeon
holes, as they were called.
Each of those represent different ships.
We place mail in those slots and we wait
'till the vessel is actually coming
through the Port of Detroit.
- [Radio] Hey Dark Dan,
how you doin' today?
- Pretty good, how 'bout yourself?
- [Radio] Oh not too bad,
just getting finished up here.
- Okay real good, we'll
see you in a little bit.
(radio beeps)
- We pack the mail bags,
Captain takes the vessel
away from our dock and
off to Midstream we go.
We deliver mail by the pail.
That's the sailor's mailbox if you will.
The crewman aboard the ship
will lower down a bucket
and we'll fill the bucket with the mail
and then we send a bucket back up.
Sometimes we're delivering
passengers, crew.
We had a grocery order
a number of years ago.
The last item was about
three and a half feet long,
I looked at it and it
was a tuna, a whole tuna.
We end the delivery with a salute.
(boat horn blows)
We head back to the dock, we
wait for our next adventure.
I've worked here for 43 years.
I'm grateful to have
been a part of all this
and I look forward to a fifth generation
taking this on and seeing where it goes,
up or down the river, as it were.
(violin pulses)